Speaker 1: I want to do a kind of close the loop
on a story we've been covering, which is this U.S.
trucker convoy now you might be saying David,
the trucker convoy wasn't that like months ago
in Canada or did the U.S. convoy even actually
get started? And you would be right to be
confused because they accomplished absolutely
nothing. They got almost no attention. They were
protesting non-existent mandates. And it is now
coming to a close. This is. I have to tell you,
I love this. I take so much pleasure in this
good Daily Beast report. Peoples convoy gives up
and will leave D.C. after three weeks of doing
absolutely nothing. Our friend Zachary Patrizio
wrote this for The Daily Beast, and he explains
three weeks after the so-called people's convoy
landed in Washington, DC. The group is calling it
quits after accomplishing nothing except injuring
residents and circling the Beltway. Co-organizer
Mike Landis announced Sunday night that the group
would package things up in the coming days and
drive back to California. Landis said the convoy
goers who remained in Hagerstown, Maryland, who
had freezing nights while camping out, will enjoy
a southerly route back to California. We're
going to take a little more southern route, so
it's a little warmer than this. This is absolutely
fantastic. Now, a lot of you are probably reacting
by saying, I didn't even know that they were still
there and indeed they did nothing. Now there's
there's two parts to this. The first part is
even when the Canadian trucker convoy got going,
they were mostly protesting non-existent mandates.
And since then, even more vaccine requirements
have been dropped now in the United States. The
U.S. trucker convoy is quite literally protesting
for freedom that they have. I mean, there's almost
no vaccine requirements remaining for people
who are within the United States. If their own
company requires them to be vaccinated or tested,
that's their company policy. The Supreme
Court already said that Joe Biden, forcing
companies with over 100 employees to require
vaccination or testing, had to be halted. So
at its core, this was a movement about
something that is not actually a problem.
But the second part of this that I find just
particularly funny is these are people who
were I don't want to call it rallying. They were
basically driving around. Framing themselves as
the victims of government tyranny and as their
convoy started to come east from the West Coast,
Russia invades Ukraine. Civilians are being
killed. It's a complete violation of the
sovereignty of Ukrainian borders, et cetera,
et cetera. And these truckers are trying to say
they're the ones that are being victimized by
tyranny. Like it's what's happening in Ukraine
is absolutely horrifying. Just one of the most one
of the most horrible things that's happened in the
last couple of years. But there's some hilarious
irony to the fact that when there are real victims
of government authoritarianism, I'm talking about
Ukrainian victims of Putin's authoritarianism
and belligerence. You've got truckers who are
like, I don't want to get vaccinated. I don't
want to get vaccinated. The big headlines from
the trucker convoy. About a week ago, someone on
a bicycle got in front of the convoy and almost
shot the entire thing down. They didn't even
know how to get around the biker, and it barely
got any attention. They accomplished nothing,
and the entire reason for being was bogus. Given
the reduction in all sorts of different mask
vaccine and testing requirements in the United
States, let's hope that we're closing the book
on this pathetic excuse for activism that is
actually just a waste of everyone's time and
particularly inconvenient to people who are
just trying to get to work and earn a living.